well hey dodgers i mean it's a big story  here in la  last night's world series game had a lot  of incredible highlights  one of the stranger moments though came  when dodgers star player  justin turner was suddenly pulled  late in the game because he tested  positive for the coronavirus  yeah now with all the players  quarantining during the series people  are wondering  how did he get the coronavirus how could  this have happened  but if you watch last night's game well  sadly i think the answer is obvious  and batting next shortstop joey wendell  while they clear the plate folks let's  have a little fun with our game six  cough cam there's the little cofferoo  anything will do  that's a grand slam of germs and the  crowds loving it  what do we have here no cough but that  player  is spitting pretty how about that  look at all that  you